this will be on youtube yes all of the
speed runs will be on youtube
but i'm releasing them slowly to give
people a chance to watch okay so
again we see a perk
and i really met the perk in a disreport
i didn't know that the the this many
1600s played the perk
and um okay let's go with the austrian
so jose wanted me to play an austrian
attack which is f4 where you arrange
thank you cj hamster where you arrange
these three pawns like this
and basically the austrian the austrian
attack
builds it builds a big center and and
what you're not trying to do here with
white is
you're not trying to attack on the
king's side yet you're you're banking on
the center
and you need to develop your pieces with
an eye toward
toward supporting the center as much as
possible so that you don't overextend
yourself so that you don't bite off more
than he
you can chew and so the move bishop c4
would be a mistake here
uh and a very instructor and fall into a
tactic that we've talked about several
times
uh which is knight takes e4 and d5 i'll
show that after the game
so we actually want to put the bishop on
d3 i know some of you might be looking
at this and say what is the bishop doing
uh but again not every one of your
pieces needs to be
you know ascending mount everest at
every moment it can just be
lending some support to the center and
guess what because we've positioned our
pieces in a healthy way we can
expand uh even further let's go e5 let's
expand a little bit further because
that's the point which which pawn should
we take with this is actually
an instructor which font do you guys
think and we can take with either pawn
but this is actually a very interesting
moment
yeah so so okay so this is really
interesting
we can take with the f-bomb right and
and the argument for that move
would be that we open up the bishop and
if we open up the bishop that means
we can try to quickly run our h-bond out
up the board and checkmate him
and we're going to try to do that just
for fun but
if you want to know what i would have
done in a real game i would have taken
with the d-pawn and after the game i
will explain
exactly why so you guys have something
to look forward to
so here goes knight g4 okay uh let's
let's let's get it get rid of it get out
get out get out i
don't want you there and let's get our
bishop out of course
gotta get our bishop out and look look
where i'm putting it i'm putting it on a
square such that it over protects the
pawn
and this move is part of the reason why
i would have taken to the d-pad but in
this position
it's not good or it's not as effective
because
this is why i put the bishop here what
can we now do how do we
react to our opponent's attempt to break
up our pawn structure
the principles to capture toward the
center but it has a lot of extent well
no if we disregard it then he can take
our pawn and attack the knight so we can
just push
uh if we go queen d2 then he can take
our pawn on d4
break up our pawn chain and if we take
his knight then he takes hours
thank you for tuning chess coach for the
raid of the party 19 appreciate it
okay queen b6 uh so he attacks the pawn
but um this one we can disregard
because our control over the center is
so overwhelming
that we can just accumulate the pressure
and we can do that with queen d2
we attack the knight and if he takes on
b2
then he's probably going to end up
losing a piece
and if he does that i'll show you guys
how
uh but uh yep so first things first
he's attacking our rook so we cannot
take the knight yet he's gonna take our
rook with chair we gotta move our rook
first
now queen yeah why not now
what should we do now and this is the
key move
uh because if we take our the knight on
h6 then he's gonna take back we take and
he takes on c3 with check so
we gotta ask ourselves the logical next
question which is can we
preemptively defend the knight somehow
preferably with tempo so that his knight
doesn't escape our clutches and
the move rook b3 presents itself the
queen has to go back
and now we have our loot we have our
knight
and uh we're up a piece and the rook
nicely defends the knight on c3 he's got
no fork because that bishop guards the
square
and uh okay so he goes 1995. um
we have a choice of several good moves
here we can we can
transition into winning a rook that
would leave him with us yeah let's do it
that would leave him with a strong
bishop right it would leave him with a
strong uncontested bishop but we are up
a rook that's that's a huge material
advantage
and also remember that we can just
castle short so we can we can
escape the immediate danger to our king
by castling short
and uh well actually if he takes back he
might give us
a check on g3 i think he probably will
my guess is he's gonna yeah
which is so which is completely
innocuous by the way and actually not a
good move because the bishop isn't doing
anything here and we can use it as a
well kind of as a pawn now
how should we go about winning this
position well what jumps to mind is the
fact that our king is is
quite clearly in a little bit of a tough
spot right it's not very safe so
the thing that we really want to do is
trade queens
and for that to happen you might notice
that the queens are making contact with
each other through the lens of this
knight
through the x-ray of the knight where
can yeah knight e4 we can move the
knight to e4 which accomplishes two
things
notice now that he put his bishop on g3
and that's exactly why it's wrong
because in addition to dealing with the
the tension between the queens
he has to also defend the bishop so he
basically has to either
well he basically has to preempt bishop
takes e4 he basically has to either
trade queens disaster because we're up a
rook
or he's got to drop his queen to c7
which allows me to root out this bishop
and you know that's a another disastrous
trait so that's it we
we trades queens and we're up a rook
okay
now let's operate step by step first of
all
well first of all let's improve our
bishop and let's get this bishop out of
the picture
then we're going to bring our king up
okay well
yeah he gives us the bishop but but if
he moved the bishop we would have
brought our king up activated the rook
cemented our
central control with c4 and won the game
after that
okay
so well it's not that he had well by the
way if he goes bishop c7
white wins on the spot here with what
move
what what does white do here yeah full
board awareness is super important like
understanding that
and i blundered a piece like this so you
know if you guys think that i'm like
this immune to these kinds of blunders
i'm not
i once wandered a bishop in exactly this
kind of way where i didn't realize the
rook
on one side of the board controls the
square on the other side of the board
um and you're like daniel i call bs on
this okay i've actually
shown this game excerpt once before a
couple of months ago
but i can show it again this is one of
the only times where i actually full on
blunder to piece in a tournament game
my rating was 2076 this was 2006.
and uh you'll see exactly what i mean
this is actually i think quite an
instructive example
and uh there's a quick story that goes
i've told this story before but um well
stories aren't meant to be repeated
just give me a second i'm setting up the
scene
a little bit here thank you uh lmao nice
for the
sub appreciate it
there we go okay
so yeah so there we go
yeah i'll show everything don't worry
all right
um so this position occurred now this
tournament was not actually san
francisco let me
change that this was in los this was in
los angeles
this was in
los angeles
yeah this was in los angeles so i had
the white pieces it's just a position
doesn't matter
i i was um i had just turned 11
uh 13 days prior and uh
you know we have a complicated position
he's got a good night he's got bad pawn
structure
uh and i've got some pressure going down
the a7 pawn
and can somebody guess what move i
played here
with with white could somebody guess
what move i played here
yeah bishop takes a7 so i thought okay i
thought okay
uh he wants to take the spawn so let me
take his pawn
and he'll take mine and then i'll get my
bishop back and great i'll
eventually get control of the a file
maybe the bishop will come back to d6
so i play bishop take say some my
opponent kind of looks at me weirdly
and i'm like okay maybe he's surprised i
didn't play rook a1 but rookie one may
be queen take c3 i think i didn't like
this
uh and and then he writes down and this
was back when people used to write moves
on the scoresheet before playing them i
think that's kind of against the rules
now or at least it's discouraged
and he writes down rook takes a sun i'm
like rook takes a so and i started
thinking okay so he wants to sack the
exchange
and and he's going to try to checkmate
me on g2 but he's i mean what the hell
is this i mean because i now have a past
pawn
and then i look a little bit further and
it's like rook g takes a7 i'm like
oh my god he had a rook there and this
is exactly the type of blunder my
opponent made right full board awareness
lack of full board awareness but here's
the funny thing i actually made a draw
i'm literally a piece down for
no compensation but i actually made a
draw which is the most
nerdisky thing ever he even forced a
queen trait i have no idea how i drew
this position
well i do i do actually he sacrificed
the knight for no reason
he played perfectly but then he
he sacks a knight in a completely
winning position
thinking that he promotes a pawn but he
doesn't and i managed to
hold the position so anyways
i managed to hold the position but but
the fact remains i
i i wanted a piece in one move like this
okay back to the speed one sorry for the
detour
all right so yeah so who didn't see the
rook
and that's kind of what what our
opponent is here it's very common
so let's go go through the game this is
another very instructive game
we played the austrian attack the
austrian attack is
frequently considered and the funny
thing is in the game that i just showed
you it started with e4d6 that's a funny
coincidence
the austrian was first played in the
year 1850 by john cochran
john cochran was also the first person
to play
some other opening we were discussing
like a day ago he was a british player
very very strong uh and and he knew
this guy knew what he was doing and it
was played throughout the 1800s but just
a couple times
and then it really gained steam about 50
years ago but nobody really played the
perk
in the 1800s because people didn't give
up control of the center like this right
it was laughed at
uh and the idea is just to get big
control of the center and now you want
to defend the pawn
bishop c4 by the way uh there's knight
takes e4 and d5
breaking into white center and and it's
just bad uh we've discussed this before
this this happens in a lot of different
openings
and that's why we play bishop d3 and we
go e5 and this is the critical moment
oh yeah johnny cochran right
um yeah i just watched people against
soj actually so why d take c5
right and people are looking at this
move thinking like this violates all the
rules
you're not taking toward the center and
you're keeping the bishop kind of closed
so let me try to explain and
the way that i'm going to explain this
is by explaining why i would be worried
about f takes e5 it's not
so much that i love the move d e
although i kind of do
and what i love about this move is that
i'm prognosticating a situation
where i'm going to put a rook on the d
file and it's gonna
x-ray the queen very painfully and i can
really do some work down this d-file
that i've opened up for myself
so no this is sparkling water i'm not
drinking a beer at
12 22 a.m before bedtime um
so that that's just sparkling water
but the mug takes e5
if he had gone 98 believe it or not i
would actually be a little bit concerned
here
because if you look at this pawn chain
it looks very good but he's actually
threatening to break up the spawn chain
with a move c5 and he made this move in
the game
and we were able to neutralize this move
by putting a bishop on f4 and preparing
to go d5 against c5 but uh
this is as you guys can see a little bit
flimsy there's a sense in which this is
just a tiny bit flimsy and
perhaps we've bitten off a little bit
more than we can show so
i'm always worried about these kinds of
pawn breaks and i don't like to allow
them
and so for that reason d takes e5 is a
little bit safer both moves are good
take the advice of capturing toward the
center of the grain of salt
thank you vic scorcher i appreciate it
take that advice with a grain of salt
because it's got a lot of exceptions
it's among the rules that are
that are i would say violated perhaps
the most it's not
i don't think it should even be a big
piece of advice i think it should be
like uh
something that's accompanied with an
asterisk
so anyways
and the dark squared bishop mr shelby
can go out to e3 which is perfectly fine
and by the way it stops the d7 knight
from coming to c5 which is also good
which means that the bishop is going to
remain kind of locked in
okay so what else happened in this game
so boom boom boom boom
queen d2 attack now he should have moved
his knight to f5
he probably didn't want to allow this
very ugly pawn structure in front of the
king which is what makes it important we
would have castled
look at how beautiful white's position
is center we can go
g4 to make the king side explode that
would be the idea
and uh this would be crushing so he
takes
and now the chemo is rook b3 right if we
take on h6
uh we win the piece it seems but we give
up the knight with check
otherwise we would have had knight g5
mating him so we go rook b3 this is the
kind of stuff you always have to look
for when you have a situation
where two pieces are kind of hanging you
want to see if you can defend one of
them with tempo
and then we take on h6 and by the way
some people might be wondering why we
didn't do this
seemingly winning another piece isn't
that better than winning a rook
winning two pieces but the problem is he
can make an intermediate move capture
our knight
and we're only up a piece for a pawn i
guess
which is worse than being up a rook the
good thing about this is that we've
eliminated his strongest piece
so it's actually not entirely obvious
thank you big score show
he should have just taken on f8 right uh
because now we if we got 94 he at least
can move his queen back without giving
up the bishop thank you
dolphin big score show throwing out
those bits appreciate it my man
and uh after 94 the game is over because
uh
because we basically either force the
queen trade or we force him to give up
his bishop
um yeah but the thing is he's easy it's
it's like you're um
you know how what analogy should i i'm
trying to think of the right analogy for
explaining why this is not that
important
it's like you're you know
you're fighting a a boss in a video game
you know those video games where you
fight a boss at the end
and you know you're deciding
which of his toenails to like shoot at
but
the the like huge monster is not gonna
feel a little
slingshot thrown at his toenail i know
it's a weird comparison
we're up a rook so it doesn't matter
this bishop could be in my grill it
could be
well it could be in a place where the
sun doesn't shine it doesn't matter why
it is
so the rook is such an overwhelming
material advantage in the end game
that barring some sort of crazy
difference in peace placement
it's not gonna matter where you put the
bishop thank you blunderbar for the tier
three
blunderbro with a tier three sub
appreciate it man
yeah it's like david is fighting goliath
and david is like man should i
should i aim my slingshot at his like
second
toe or his third toe like goliath is not
going to feel any of that thank you
nicola for the thousand
bits my man
ah appreciate it
and thank you big scorcho for another
hundred well definitely i was proud
i wasn't just proud of charlie i was
well that was one of
my most memorable days in the past year
so we had one more question
which is why did i not yeah queen c1
would have been possible but the
downside of this move is that it would
make it harder to castle long
so if if you compare queen c1 knight f5
takes takes here we would just
love to castle long uh to be able to
attack on the other side of the board
as it stands thank you nicola for
gifting to photochest
as it stands uh we can't do that and as
we showed in the game uh
queen takes me two is nothing to be
afraid of okay
so let's play one more hey photochest
and let me just take my sweatshirt off
one sec
yeah so why didn't we play b3 precisely
for the same reason
that we didn't play queens to it because
we don't actually need to defend the
spawn
because if he takes it he loses the
knight which is exactly what happened
um okay so that is that game let's play
one more
and analyze it of course he's easy my
pleasure
yeah we've got tons of incredibly
generous supporters
which i am incredibly fortunate to have
okay let's go
well it is what it is uh ex kyle people
just have to
live with it
okay we are uh seeking a game
we have one against zek 007
okay so knight f3 that's the first
instance of this move we face let's go
d5
um we've been playing the queen's gambit
which is a little bit boring
but it also allows us to emphasize
application of regular themes
so he plays the london and actually a an
underestimated
move against the london is just to copy
it people don't do this enough they play
e6 all the time
but if we just copy the london moves uh
we're going to neutralize the music now
here
does anybody know what typical move is
often made
when we have a standoff between the
bishops
what what typically do we do when we
have this standoff
yeah bishop g6 is right good job
uh and i'll explain after the game why
it is that that trading
is trading is not bad uh but it's it's
subpar
so we can do the same thing it's a
boring position but you got to be able
to play these that's part of chess
this is as much a chess position as
anything else
and now uh well we should castle we
should definitely castle
and and develop and then we can
undermine the night
how how do we undermine the night what
typically another very typical moment in
london for black
uh which in the idea is to
is to um yeah so c5 is right undermining
the knight and staking a
bet bigger claim this and also you're
kind of paving the way for the
development of the knight to c6
and our ultimate aim is to smoke out
this knight from e5 that is the pride of
white's position
that is the knight that we are trying to
target and we're going to apply
methodical pressure to this knight
but he's gone g4 so let's unpack this
mode for a second it's not a good move
um and the reason that it's not a good
move
is because we can actually win a pawn
here but we need to get the sequence of
moves right
so what is defending this pawn there's
two pieces
defending pawn on g4 there's the queen
and the knight
and we have one attacker on this one let
me draw it with a different colored
arrow
actually i can't so we have a knight
attacking g4
and we have a queen and a knight
defending it hypothetically
if we removed both of his defenders from
the pawn on g4 then we could win it so
we could first take the bishop and then
take the knight or
but if we take the bishop he'll take
with the knight and the queen will
remain a defender of the pawn
so we first take the knight that's one
defender and this reminds me of a movie
scene i'll show you guys after then we
take the bishop
i know exactly and i've shown this
before i know
exactly what to show you guys after this
knight takes g4
boom goes the dynamite and we have the
pawn and
we also are attacked now some of you
might be asking i know a lot of people
are thinking this
isn't it dangerous to open the g file
which is a direct artery to the king
the answer is no because because he
doesn't have any pieces in the attack
and also because here's another pawn and
this knight could throw its body against
a rook that lands on g1 it would just be
biting on granite
so as long as we're careful uh his king
is also super weak we should we should
so let's actually do that let's drop the
knight to g6 so that if he puts a rook
on g1
uh that rook is going to be entirely
neutralized also we can break through in
the center with d4
especially since his king is still in
the center which is what we're going to
do let's break through with d4 while his
king is still in the center let's strike
while the iron is hot
thank you domain appreciate it that was
very satisfying boom boom boom
and trust me guys i know it's a show so
which pawn should we
should we take upon if so which punch
should we take you guys already know the
principle about
king safety and pawn structure we should
definitely take
this one to introduce and let's go after
his pawns with queen a5
going after his newly weakened pawns now
let's we shouldn't expect to to mate him
in the next five move okay so he's
he's just hemorrhaging pawns here here's
another one now we're three pawns up
we shouldn't expect to mate him anytime
soon but we're up a million pawns and
even a queen trade would be entirely
satisfactory here
given that we are up three pawns
uh now a good move would be to go c4
attacking the knight he he might go rook
c1 in fact he probably will
i've anticipated this and there's a
hidden idea okay no actually he doesn't
um now we could trade but we can make a
very clever move you guys ready for a
very clever move
here's the thing that i'm noticing what
i'm noticing is that if he takes on c6 i
know that looks like
uh it might be bad for us because it
ruins the pawn structure but if we play
b take c6 we'll open up the b file guess
what's on the b file
white's king there's one small problem
which is that the bishop on g3 is
covering
the b8 square on which a rook could
potentially appear
so we need to both lure him into taking
r knight and
if possible uh impede the bishop's
control of that square we can do that
with the movie five
exactly good job now if if white is
knows what he's doing he's probably he
shouldn't take this knight that would be
disaster immediately
but there's a high probability he
doesn't he he
can't resist the temptation i think he
will the fact that he's thinking
is telling me that he smells a rat but
on the other hand if he moves the knight
away
then our position remains whole yeah he
moves the knight away but now we have a
tempo
what do we use this tempo to do we can
use this tempo to bring another piece
into the game such as a rook to d8
and uh yeah it's a good move it's you
know one of many possible moves
and now we can stick this rook right
into his grill here on d3 that's a
typical
typical move where it's supported by a
pawn and and now this
where is this knight going there is one
square that i'm seeing
which is the juiciest square of all time
forget that i have any pieces on that
where does this night belong
name a square and there is a currently a
piece on that square but we'll get that
piece out of that school
no not before no no no no think think
big think oh
that square is a family fork against the
queen the king the queen of the rock
what are our next two moves likely going
to be knight t5 queen a5 like
boom boom simple chess here comes knight
d5
if he goes e4 then yes then yes we might
have to put our knight on b4 which is
the next best thing by the way
and wait let me think about this
oh we have a beautiful move we have a
beautiful tactic here
now we're thinking about where to move
this queen and the ideal thing
is if we're moving this queen to deliver
a fork against his why don't we
sacrifice this queen
for something and then we win his entire
queen
back and then we'll end up
up a lot of material presumably now i'm
oversimplifying this and i'll explain
the
full extent of the calculations after
the game
but we can take the rook queen against
three pieces here that's actually super
nice
three bucks from sucher thank you
and the reason this seems like a big
mistake
is because his queen can take on e1
that's where calcium
that's what he does but i've anticipated
this what can we do
what's the idea yeah so we play rook
takes d1 luring the queen
back to a forkable square where we fork
it and pick it off and we're up in
exchange and
four pawns in the end game i think
that's enough to win the game
that's it that's all there is to it and
we're just gonna push our pass pawns
here again identify the
region of the board where you have
passpons let's get this rook into the
game
and push them while activating all of
your pieces we don't even need to
activate our king here because
we have an abundance of resources with
which to win the game
there was probably something even better
in terms of delivering checkmate but
this was the simplest yeah because now
we can basically play on automatic
hundred picks thank you
oh italians have a very vast history in
chess
okay let's get this pawn pushed let's
get these pawns
on the road okay let's not give up our
rook let's give a check
king a2 we can continue pushing if he
takes we can take with the knight
because what we really need to promote
is this c pawn the c pawn now has a
direct path
to heaven
although maybe not but yeah he can you
can give up his knight for it
okay now we're up a full rook and now
we're going to start pushing the pawns
on the other side of the board his
bishop is just going to be completely
overwhelmed
okay so let's first push this one then
we're going to push this pawn and we're
going to checkmate him on b2
his bishop is going to be completely
well he's probably going to go e6
yep now his bishop is overwhelmed
covering this one and that
this is what's called trousers and now
it's checkmate bishop literally can't
cover both at the same time
now um what we did in the opening here
now bishop g6 what is the idea what is
the idea of bishop g6 the idea bishop g6
by and large is that if if white takes
the bishop you play hg
and you open up a very nice little h
file for yourself big score show gifting
too
you're still thank you and that
basically
gives black a very very nice source of
tension already
as early as like move six uh now why
is it not an ideal idea to catch around
because he plays cd and and the queen
immediately gets a very nice avenue
to come to b3 and apply pressure on the
b7 pawn and then very quickly
white's going to get all his pieces out
on the queen side black's queen side is
going to get under a lot of fire here
so um so this is just
a little bit nasty uh and for that
reason you want to keep the tension
now the move g4 is is obviously very
premature
and this idea of capturing one piece
it's like you're standing in line
at a buffet and you're
starving but there's a bunch of people
in front of you taking forever to get
food onto their plates and you want to
get them out of the picture
uh so you take one and then you you know
blow the napkin off of another person's
plate
and then finally you're at the front of
the line and you play knight xg4
and there is a movie scene that captures
this idea
perfectly and i think you guys will
appreciate this
let me find it
yeah it's working now we can watch that
other movie
so mr bean gets in line and he's
yeah so he he knocks the fork off of one
person
and then he blows the napkin off of
another
and now it's a very funny scene because
and now he's at the front of the line
and now you guys will never forget the
idea behind
the move bishop takes e5 bishop takes e3
right you're mr bean
you're removing the defenders one by one
of the pawn on g4
and that is kasparov behind me yes but
if you take on d3 first then the knight
takes so the order of operations
please excuse my dear aunt sally is very
important
so we take take take he should have
defended the pawn with knight f3 at
least preserving
one pawn but he didn't he actually
forced us to take the other one
now we open up the center and let's fast
forward
and the movie five is actually very
important right because we're luring him
into taking on c6 so that we then get a
rook on we can pre-move this move rook
b8
it's going to be either checkmating or
winning a bunch of his pieces or both
um so he drops his knight back we stick
a rook here
get the knight over to d5 and now the
key move
uh queen takes c1 oh by the way uh if if
he had gone roxy one trying to win the
pawn
like forcing our queen away where would
i have put the queen what was the idea
what was the queen d3 check so the idea
is to use this pawn now as an
anchor for the queen and trade queens
and remember we are up
three pawns that's a huge advantage and
we can even give up one of them if it
means we get into an end game
so this is a simple sort of a simple
decision probably not the best move but
it's simple enough and it does the trick
now the move queen takes you
so again if he takes with the knight or
if he takes to the rook
our response is the same we go knight c3
check
and actually for extra credit we would
flick in another check
just to get his king out of the picture
and then we would take the queen he
would take hours and
at the end of the day we'd end up a
piece up the same thing would happen
if he took with the the rook but he took
with the queen and this is where it's
super important to calculate until the
end of each line
rook takes d1 is the key thank you rich
and pure for the prime
getting the queen onto a forkable square
boom
pork winning everything so that was the
the game well i appreciate that people
enjoy this one